[Musique]
cette vidéo est destinée aux étudiants
de prépa ECG anciennement prépa HEC en
effet les épreuves de dissertation de
culture générale des concours des
grandes écoles de commerce qui auront
lieu l'année prochaine en 2024 ces
épreuves de dissertation porteront sur
le thème de la violence
deux petites précisions avant de
commencer à vous faire découvrir ce
thème tout d'abord vous n'avez pas
besoin de prendre de notes en regardant
cette vidéo car vous pouvez télécharger
mon kit de survie sur le thème de la
violence c'est un fichier Google Docs
d'une vingtaine de pages qui contient
l'essentiel à connaître sur le thème de
la violence pour réussir vos
dissertations non seulement il est
organisé efficacement mais en plus vous
pouvez accéder directement à la partie
qui vous intéresse grâce au sommaire
dynamique sur la gauche personnellement
je suis fan de Google Docs depuis que
cette fonctionnalité existe d'ailleurs
vous pouvez faire la même chose avec
cette vidéo grâce au chapitre qui
apparaissent dans la barre de lecture je
les ai également listé dans la
description enfin vous pouvez même
customiser ce document Google Docs en
créant une copie personnelle mais bon
méfiance tout de même parce qu'il y a
déjà beaucoup de choses et plus vous
aurez de connaissances à gérer moins
vous les maîtriserez et donc moins vous
serez en mesure de réussir vos
dissertations pour accéder à ce kit de
survie cliquez sur le lien qui apparaît
en haut à droite de la vidéo ou bien
cliquez sur celui qui est dans la
description ou bien encore taper
directement 1000 idées cg.com/biolence
dans la barre de recherche ensuite il
vous suffira de vous inscrire avec votre
adresse email de confirmer votre
inscription en ouvrant le premier email
que vous recevrez et vous recevrez alors
ce kit de survie dans l'e-mail suivant
s'il y a un souci vous pouvez m'écrire à
Romain @1cg.com
seconde précision préliminaire inspirée
par le fait que pas mal d'élèves m'ont
déjà posé la même question oui je vais
bien proposer mes 50 paragraphes tout
cuits sur le thème de la violence comme
chaque année il n'y a que 100 places
c'est pourquoi certains élèves ont déjà
réservé la leur si ça vous intéresse
cliquez sur le lien qui apparaît en haut
à droite de la vidéo ou bien cliquez sur
celui qui est dans la description ou
bien encore taper directement 1000 idées
cg.com/50ptc dans la barre de recherche
bien sûr vous pouvez me poser vos
questions par email en écrivant à
romain@mie l'idée cg.com
voilà voilà c'est bon pour les
précisions préliminaires et je vais
maintenant vous présenter l'essentiel à
connaître sur le thème de la violence
pour réussir vos dissertations de
culture générale
tout d'abord les caractéristiques du
thème
je vais répondre à deux questions pour
mettre en évidence les principales
caractéristiques du thème de la violence
première question est-ce un thème
original et puis seconde question est-ce
un thème précis ou large
est-ce un thème original
en prépa ECG HEC le thème la violence
n'est jamais tombé depuis les années
1990 le seul thème passé qui s'en
rapproche et le mal tombé en 2001 alors
que la violence est une obsession de
l'être humain elle est avec la sexualité
un des deux stimuli les plus puissants
pour capter son attention on ne peut
cependant pas dire qu'elle soit un thème
classique en culture générale les
grandes œuvres de la littérature et de
la philosophie occidentale ne traite pas
spécifiquement de la violence si ce
n'est de manière adjacente lorsqu'elle
traite de la guerre notamment ce n'est
pas une notion du programme de
philosophie de terminale et ce n'est pas
non plus un axe du programme de culture
générale de première année en conclusion
le thème de la violence est plutôt
original
est-ce un thème précis ou large
d'un côté le thème de la violence semble
précis parce que la polysémie du mot est
limitée la définition du dictionnaire de
l'Académie française est relativement
courte parce que ce thème est moins
général que d’autres comme le monde le
thème de l'année dernière par exemple ou
le mal et enfin parce que le nombre de
sous thèmes apparaît limité
mais d'un autre côté le thème de la
violence semble large dans la mesure où
c'est une obsession de l'être humain
dans la mesure où on distingue de
nombreuses formes de violence physique
psychologiques verbales et sexuelle
domestique économique politique
symbolique structurel individuel
collective etc et encore dans la mesure
où elle est une dimension majeure de
l'histoire récente disons depuis la
Révolution française et tout
particulièrement le 20e siècle
en définitive comparé à tous les thèmes
qui sont tombés au concours des grandes
écoles de commerce le thème de la
violence est plutôt précis
les définitions essentielles
je vais tout d'abord définir la notion
de violence elle-même en partant de ce
étymologie je vais ensuite vous donner
les définitions simples d'une dizaine de
concepts clés qui sont liés à la notion
de violence
comment définir la violence sur le plan
de l'étymologie le nom commun violent
vient du latin violencia qui signifie
essentiellement en force et qui sert
notamment à qualifier la capacité de
certains phénomènes naturels à faire
subir une contrainte physique à l'homme
la force du vent par exemple
le mot latin violencia vient lui-même du
latin whis viess qui signifie également
la force mais au sens de force vitale
d'énergie en action c'est à dire ce qui
fait mouvoir les êtres vivants dans
cette perspective la violence est liée à
la vie elle-même l'idée que suggère
l'étymologie latine et donc qu'il y a
violence lorsque l'énergie qui anime la
vie se fait sentir physiquement au point
d'engendrer un dommage
en français le sens le plus courant du
nom commun violence concernant en effet
les actions physiques et les
comportements
pour faire simple il faut distinguer
deux usages du mot violence tout d'abord
la force elle-même c'est le fait d'agir
sur quelqu'un ou de le faire agir contre
sa volonté en employant la force ou
l'intimidation les dommages sont en
général physique mais ils peuvent être
et ils sont de plus en plus
psychologiques comme dans le harcèlement
on parle par exemple de la violence
révolutionnaire des violences policières
ou de la violence conjugale dans cet
usage la violence s'oppose à la paix et
à l'ordre
second usage du mot violence la manière
d'être de la force c'est essentiellement
le fait que la force n'est pas contenue
et l'homme estime qu'elle devrait l'être
parce qu'elle risque d'engendrer un
dommage on parle par exemple de la
violence du vent de la violence d'un
coup le coût constituant en lui-même une
violence ou de la violence d'une
accusation dans cet usage la violence
s'oppose à la mesure
la longue ordinaire distingue certaines
formes de violence dont notamment la
violence physique la violence verbale la
violence psychologique la violence
sexuelle ou encore la violence
structurelle lorsque l’organisation de
la société la configuration hiérarchique
de ces éléments et source de violence ou
encore la violence symbolique idée issue
de la sociologie de Bourdieu
quelles sont les idées les plus
importantes
voici les principales idées liées à la
notion de violence
l'agression c'est l'atteinte à
l'intégrité physique ou psychologique
d'un organisme on peut dire par exemple
ressentir le bruit comme une agression
la barbarie c'est le caractère d'une
violence dont l'excès est rapporté à la
prétendue sauvagerie de la vie humaine
dans l'état précédent la civilisation on
peut dire par exemple pousser la
répression jusqu'à la barbarie
la brutalité c'est le caractère d'une
chose dont l'intensité frappe l'esprit
humain de la même manière que
l'intensité du comportement d'une brut
un animal dépourvu de raison frappe
l'esprit on peut dire par exemple la
brutalité d'une offensive militaire
la coopération c'est l'entente entre les
membres d'un groupe en vue d'un but
commun on peut dire par exemple
travailler en étroite coopération
la cruauté c'est le caractère d'une
violence qui laisse penser que son
auteur est insensible à la souffrance de
la victime on peut dire par exemple
traiter ses ennemis avec cruauté
la domination c'est l'action ou la
capacité d'un individu ou d'une entité à
imposer sa volonté à quelqu'un ou
quelque chose on peut dire par exemple
l'Empire romain étant sa domination
un dommage c'est un préjudice physique
ou psychologique causé par un tiers on
peut dire par exemple les dommages
incalculables de la guerre
la force c'est la capacité d'un être
vivant ou d'une chose à exercer une
action on peut dire par exemple ne plus
avoir la force d'avancer
la guerre c'est un conflit armé entre
des groupes humains organisés vous
connaissez peut-être l'art de la guerre
le chef-d'œuvre de sunsu
l'intégrité c'est l'état d'un ensemble
une chose ou un être qui est complet
dont il ne manque aucune des parties on
peut dire par exemple une atteinte à
l'intégrité physique
l'intimidation c'est l'action de
susciter la crainte chez un être vivant
et on peut dire par exemple ne pas céder
à des manœuvres d'intimidation
la paix c'est l'absence de troubles dans
les relations entre individus ou entre
groupes d'individus et on peut dire par
exemple faire la paix la peur c'est
l'émotion pénible liée à la conscience
d'un danger il y a par exemple la peur
de la mort
la souffrance c'est une douleur physique
ou morale on parle par exemple de la
souffrance animale
la torture c'est une souffrance physique
intense infligée à quelqu'un souvent
pour obtenir des aveux on parle par
exemple des instruments de torture
la tyrannie c'est une domination qui
parce qu'elle n'est pas encadrée par des
limites recours à la violence et commet
l'injustice on peut parler par exemple
de la tyrannie d'un dirigeant qui
réprime les oppositions à sa politique
enfin la vengeance c'est l'acte
d'infliger un dommage en réponse à un
dommage subi on peut dire par exemple
goûter le plaisir de la vengeance
[Musique]
vu dans ensemble sur la violence humaine
dans cette partie mon objectif est de
vous brosser les grandes lignes de
l'histoire de la violence humaine et des
interprétations que la pensée
occidentale en a donné ma perspective
est donc principalement historique et
philosophique toutefois je mobiliserai
aussi d'autres champs du savoir qui
permettent de mieux comprendre la
violence notamment l'anthropologie et la
psychologie voici les limites de ma
synthèse comme la violence est un
phénomène et un enjeu majeur de la vie
humaine la quantité de fait d'idées et
d’œuvres qu'on peut mentionner est
infini je me contenterai donc de
mentionner des repères essentiels autre
limite comme une vue d'ensemble est une
synthèse je vais sacrifier les détails
et simplifier parfois dans une
proportion qui peut paraître excessive
libre à vous de compléter mais
rappelez-vous que votre objectif n'est
pas d'accumuler les connaissances il est
de réussir une épreuve de dissertation
dernière limite principale de ma
synthèse ma synthèse embrasse l'histoire
de l'ensemble de l'humanité mais comme
la plupart des travaux sur le même sujet
elle donne une place plus importante à
l'Occident elle privilégie également les
violences physiques qui sont celles
auxquelles leur envoient en priorité le
mot dans la langue courante
gardez donc bien à l'esprit lorsque vous
lisez ou lorsque vous écoutez ma
synthèse que l’intérêt d'avoir une bonne
perspective d'ensemble du thème ainsi
vous vous repérerez mieux dans le champ
intellectuel sur lequel vous devrez
disserter cette année
quelle différence entre les violences
humaines et animales
voici les principales conclusions de
l'éthologie la science du comportement
des espèces animales dans leur milieu
naturel les animaux d’espèces
différentes ou bien assez vite ou bien
s'affrontent dans une relation de
prédation l'agression fonctionne comme
un instinct c'est à dire de manière
programmée et automatique surtout à
l'intérieur de l'espèce l'agression au
sein de l'espèce intervient dans la
répartition des ressources dans la
sexualité et dans l'établissement d'une
hiérarchie stable elle est peu
dangereuse les armes des animaux sont
limitées ils ont des griffes des dents
des cornes etc et l'agression sa sortie
de comportement de ritualisation qui
épargnent le plus faible enfin il existe
quand même des comportements
pathologiques lorsque la ritualisation
est défaillante il existe par exemple
des animaux tueurs il y a
l'auto-agression le cannibalisme à
l'égard des petits des attaques
pathologiques des guerres à l'intérieur
du groupe etc
d'après ces conclusions la violence
animale serait liée à un instinct qui
organise les relations des individus à
travers leurs affrontements cet instinct
existerait chez l'homme tant qu'il vit
dans des groupes dit naturelles maximum
une centaine de membres parce que chaque
membre connaît intimement les autres
membres mais l’instin déraille dans les
grands groupes dit artificiels la
distance entre les individus les empêche
de se connaître intimement et de
communiquer efficacement d'où l'échec de
la ritualisation de la violence de
surcroît les armes et l'inventivité
technique humaine démultiplie les
ravages
le zoologiste autrichien du 20e siècle
Conrad Lorenz mais par exemple en
débitant se le fait que les armes
modernes engendrent un aléa moral
l'homme qui appuie sur un bouton n'a pas
à en subir les conséquences l'invention
d'armes artificielles troubla
l’équilibre entre les possibilités de
tuer et les inhibitions sociales écrit
Conrad Lorraine ce dans l'agression une
histoire naturelle du mal l'homme serait
donc un animal agressif qui pratique à
vase échelle ce qui passe chez les
autres animaux pour une défaillance de
l'instinct
que sait-on de la violence chez les
premiers hommes
les corps d'homme préhistoriques qu'on
retrouve révèle souvent à l'analyse des
traces de violence c'est par exemple le
cas deux-tsi l'homme des glaces est
découvert en 1991 au nord-est de
l'Italie alors que les scientifiques
pensaient d'abord qu'il était mort de
froid dans une crevasse où il était
tombé des radiologues découvrent une
pointe de flèche fichée dans son épaule
puis on trouve des entailles non
cicatrisées au niveau de ses mains ainsi
que des blessures à la tête et au torse
enfin les analyses ADN identifient des
traces de sang d'autres individus la
conclusion s'impose Etsy était un homme
dangereux il faisait probablement partie
d'un groupe qui se livrait à de vieux
lampillages et qui se serait heurté à
une tribu voisine cet exemple laisse
donc penser que l'homme préhistorique
n'était pas pacifique et qu'il avait de
fortes chances de voir son corps meurtri
[Musique]
on peut mettre cette hypothèse à
l'épreuve en s'intéressant au
comportement des primates proches des
ancêtres de l'homme préhistorique les
chimpanzés les animaux les plus proches
des êtres humains passaient pour une
espèce essentiellement pacifique les
anthropologues pensaient que les
conflits entre les groupes de chimpanzés
ne dépassaient jamais le stade de
l'intimidation concrètement lorsqu'un
sous-groupe en quête de nourriture dans
la forêt rencontre un sous-groupe d'une
autre communauté les deux sous-groupes
ce livre simplement à des démonstrations
de force jusqu'à ce que l'un des deux
sous-groupes cède
mais la primatologue britannique est
Jane Goudal rétablit la vérité dans les
années 1960 observant des chimpanzés
dans leur milieu naturel sur de longues
périodes ce qu'elle est la première à
faire elle montre que l'agression
mortelle fait partie du répertoire
normal du comportement des chimpanzés en
particulier un groupe de chimpanzés mâle
peuvent faire preuve d'une sauvagerie
meurtrière lorsqu'il rencontre un plus
petit groupe d'une autre communauté ou
un individu isolé si c'est une femelle
ils peuvent la violer voire tuer et même
manger son petit les attaques par
d'autres chimpanzés sont la deuxième
cause de mortalité à gamber en Tanzanie
après les maladies écrit Jane goodal
dans free window
comment expliquer la violence des
chimpanzés dans la perspective
évolutionniste l'agression est un moyen
efficace pour les mâles d'accaparer des
ressources du territoire donc de la
nourriture et aussi des femelles du
groupe vaincu mais il ne s'adonne pas à
n'importe quel type d'agression il
privilégie les combats inégaux le groupe
des agresseurs et c'est en général
d'être trois fois plus nombreux que le
groupe des agressés afin de réduire les
risques cette situation se produit
notamment lorsque des chimpanzés affamés
se mettent en quête de nourriture seul
car les arbres à fruits sont distribués
de manière irrégulière sur le territoire
les bonobos sont d'autres primates dont
les hommes sont proches apparemment peut
porter à la violence ils ont même été
surnommés les chimpanzés hippies le
bonobo est un chimpanzé nain parce que
cette espèce serait à la fois Pacifique
matriarcale voluptueuse il dit ceci la
sexualité de la reproduction et
herbivore ils ont même donné leur nom à
un restaurant végétarien de New York
cette vision est cependant à nuancer car
les groupes de bonobos qui l'ont inspiré
sont privilégiés on a constaté que les
groupes moins privilégiés sont plus
agressifs quoique plus pacifique que les
chimpanzés communs on peut également
éclairer la propension à la violence des
ancêtres de l'homme en s'intéressant au
tribus de chasseurs-cueilleurs on a cru
jusqu'à la fin du 20e siècle que leur
violence était très limitée notamment en
comparaison des carnages dont sont
capables les sociétés plus avancées on
pensait que les affrontements tribaux
étaient essentiellement rituels et
symboliques à quoi ressemblait-il
concrètement deux camps se menacent et
s'insultent à distance ils se vise avec
des flèches et des lances puis ils
arrêtent les frais dès les premiers
bless és ou tués l'historien américain
William et carte eckk hrdt cet historien
américain qui a écrit une histoire
quantitative de la guerre en 1992 estime
que les tribus étaient trop petites et
qu'elles avaient trop peu d'armes pour
mener une guerre d'envergure
mais des anthropologues réfutent cette
conclusion au tournant du 21e siècle
l'idée essentielle qui ressort de leurs
travaux c'est que ce ne sont pas les
affrontements bruyants des tribus qui
font beaucoup de victimes mais les raids
c'est à dire les attaques sournoises la
source de la violence des
chasseurs-cueilleurs serait donc le même
type de comportement que chez les
chimpanzés concrètement un petit groupe
d'hommes se glissent furtivement dans un
village ennemi avant le lever du jour
puis décoche des flèches contre les
habitants qui sortent de leur hutte ils
peuvent ainsi tuer un grand nombre de
personnes mal réveillées le temps que
les villageois organisent la riposte les
assaillants auront déjà décampé s'ils
sont suffisamment nombreux ils peuvent
tuer tous les hommes et enlever les
femmes d'autres types d'attaques sont
possibles comme l'embuscade ou certaines
ruses ces attaques susceptibles de
décimer une tribu ne sont pas forcément
des événements rares en général les
guerres dans les sociétés préétatiques
étaient à la fois fréquentes et
importante écrit Lawrence qu'il est dans
les guerres préhistoriques
cette anthropologue américain estime
même que la guerre préhistorique était
plus meurtrière en proportion de la
population que la guerre moderne et que
ce que nous appelons des génocides
étaient monnaie courante
voici quelques autres faits révélateurs
selon les enquêtes ethnographiques
environ les deux tiers des groupes de
chasseurs-cueilleurs sont en guerre au
moins une fois tous les deux ans ces
groupes se battent souvent pour se
venger et c'est ce motif qui les incite
à massacrer leurs ennemis jusqu'au
dernier afin d'éviter un match retour
les guerriers sont capables d’être cités
par exemple ils imbibent les pointes des
flèches de poison il les conçoivent de
manière à ce qu'elle se brise au moment
de l'impact ou encore il torture leur
prisonniers enfin dernier fait
révélateur le cannibalisme est largement
répandu dans la préhistoire humaine au
point que nous posséderions des gènes
qui protègent des maladies transmises
par les pratiques cannibales
l'homme est-il violent par nature
les penseurs de référence de la culture
occidentale ont répondu à cette question
sans disposer de connaissances fiables
sur la vie humaine avant la civilisation
pour faire simple les deux positions
clés sont d'une part la vision
pessimiste développée par Thomas hopes
un philosophe anglais du XVIIe siècle
dans le Léviathan et d'autre part la
vision optimiste développée par
Jean-Jacques Rousseau un philosophe
genevois du 18e siècle dans son Discours
sur l'origine de l'inégalité leur
désaccord fondamental découle de leur
conception différentes de l'état de
nature c'est à dire la condition
hypothétique des êtres humains avant
l'établissement de la société et des
lois
en quoi hop s'est-il pessimiste à ses
yeux les premiers hommes vivaient dans
un état d'anarchie violente ce qui la
fameusement décrit comme une guerre de
tous contre tous la vie de l'homme est
solitaire besogneuse pénible quasi
animal et brève et crie Thomas dans le
Léviathan pourquoi l'état de nature
serait-il fondamentalement hostile selon
hopes c'est tout d'abord un problème de
défiance comme l'homme originel est
craint d’être attaqué à tout moment il a
intérêt à prendre lui-même l'initiative
d'attaquer c'est-à-dire qu'il attaque
par anticipation la meilleure défense
c'est l'attaque dit un adage souvent
attribué à Napoléon mais la source
primordiale de la violence de l'homme de
l'état de nature et psychologique il a
besoin de se sentir reconnu par ses
semblables il tend donc à interpréter le
moindre signe de mes estimes comme une
agression insupportable suffisante à
déclencher les hostilités cette
sensibilité le met dans une disposition
permanente au combat c'est le sens de la
célèbre formule du dramaturge latin plot
l'homme est un loup pour l'homme formule
qui sera popularisé à partir de la
Renaissance et reprise par Obs dans du
citoyen
les premiers hommes vivent donc dans un
état d'expectative qui empêche toute
activité sociale productive puisque la
violence risque de réduire à néant les
fruits de l'effort c'est pour cette
raison que Hobbs justifie l'instauration
d'un état assez fort pour interdire les
violences privées il compare la
puissance de cet état à celle du
Léviathan de la Bible un monstre marin
colossal capable d'année en tire le
monde cette solution repose sur une
conception de l'acte de violence qui met
en présence trois parties qui ont
chacune un motif de recourir à la
violence première partie l'agresseur qui
veut imposer sa volonté à une victime
seconde partie la victime qui riposte
pour se défendre et puis troisième et
dernière partie le témoin qui intervient
pour minimiser les dégâts collatéraux la
violence entre les combattants peut être
qualifiée de guerre la violence exercée
par le témoin contre les combattants
peut être qualifié de loi pour résumer
d'un mot la théorie du Léviathan la loi
vaut mieux que la guerre
en quoi Rousseau est-il optimiste à ses
yeux la violence est quasiment absente
de l'état de nature hop se trompe parce
qu'il projette les passions propres à la
société le calme des passions et
l'ignorance du vice les empêchent de mal
faire écrit Jean-Jacques Rousseau à
propos des hommes de l'état de nature
dans son Discours sur l'origine de
l'inégalité
pourquoi l'état de nature serait-il
fondamentalement Pacifique en premier
lieu c'est une question de densité de
population Rousseau postule que l'homme
préhistorique menait une vie isolée car
les individus étaient dispersés sur la
terre contrairement à la promiscuité
dans laquelle vivent les hommes
civilisés du coup les rencontres et donc
les risques de conflits sont rares en
deuxième lieu l’environnement naturel
est satisfait les besoins de l'homme ce
qui rend la prédation inutile en
troisième lieu les passions sociales la
jalousie pour faire simple les passions
sociales sont absentes de l'état de
nature de telle sorte que la violence
liée à l'honneur n'existe pas enfin même
si l'homme naturel n'est ni bon ni
mauvais car ces actes lui sont dictés
par sa survie l'homme naturel n'aime pas
la violence parce qu'il éprouve de la
pitié qui est la répugnance innée à
avoir souffrir son semblable qu'on
décède déjà chez les animaux
la vision de Rousseau a des implications
importantes dont notamment l'idée que
c'est la civilisation au sens de
l'organisation de la vie collective en
de grands groupes artificiels qui est
responsable de la violence humaine autre
implication importante la substitution
de l'idée d'innocence originelle à celle
de péché originel selon saint Augustin
la désobéissance d'Adam et Eve les
premiers humains créés par Dieu
prédisposent ensuite les hommes à faire
le mal et dernier implication importante
la révolution de l'éducation occidentale
à partir de l'idée que l'enfant est un
être innocent et pur auquel il faut
laisser la liberté de se développer
naturellement plutôt que de lui imposer
une discipline précoce
qui de hop soude Rousseau a raison le
progrès du savoir accomplit ces derniers
siècles nous permet de conclure que les
deux positions déforment très
probablement la réalité de la violence
humaine celle de Hobbs exagère la
propension de l'homme préhistorique à la
violence comme celle de Rousseau exagère
à l'innocence de cet homme les champs
modernes du savoir apportent de nouveaux
éclairages l'anthropologie mettant
lumière l'importance de la chasse cette
activité aurait développé chez les
hommes l'agressivité propre au
carnivores elle aurait en même temps
entraîné la sophistication de la
coopération une équipe de chasseurs peut
s'attaquer à du gros gibier et le
perfectionnement des outils notamment
des armes enfin comme la chasse est une
source importante d'acquisition de
nourriture les chasseurs dont la
compétence est relative à la prise de
risque et à la violence domine dans la
tribu
la psychologie mettant lumière la
coexistence de motivation qui favorise
la violence et d'autres motivations qui
ont détournent d'un côté la satisfaction
des besoins l'ambition la rivalité la
vengeance et le sadisme peuvent rendre
l’homme violent mais de l'autre côté
l'empathie la maîtrise de soi le sens
moral et la raison l'aiguille vers la
coopération et l'altruisme la
psychologie évolutionniste l'école
dominante dans la psychologie
contemporaine pose que la tendance à la
violence est stratégique c'est-à-dire
qu'en règle générale l’homme ne recourt
à la violence que lorsqu'il estime que
les gains potentiels sont élevés et les
risques faibles les hommes et les
chimpanzés comme on l'a vu ont une âme
de guerrier quand ils sont à 10 contre
un
la neurophysiologie qui étudie le
fonctionnement et l'organisation du
système nerveux mettant lumière divers
types d'agressivité il y a une
agressivité propre au cerveau reptilien
qui est le siège des comportements de
survie de l'individu et de l'espèce des
peurs ancestrales et des mécanismes de
reconnaissance de base il y a une autre
agressivité propre au système limbique
qui est le siège des motivations et des
émotions enfin il y a une autre
agressivité propre au néocortex qui
permet les anticipations les choix et le
contrôle de l'action volontaire
la sociologie qui étudie la société
comme un tout qui a ses propriétés
propres mettant en évidence divers rôles
de la violence humaine dans une
communauté par exemple la violence
initiatique le bizutage qui intègre un
nouveau membre dans un groupe la
violence qui sert à contester la
répartition des ressources ou encore la
violence entre guillemets
révolutionnaire qui sert à contester la
hiérarchie ces types de violence peuvent
exister aussi bien dans une tribu d'une
centaine de chasseurs-cueilleurs que
dans une nation de 70 millions de
citoyens enfin l'économie met en lumière
la rentabilité de la paix le commerce
est un jeu à somme positive c'est-à-dire
que toutes les parties gagnent à
coopérer or le commerçant a intérêt à ce
que ses clients et ses partenaires
soient animés par des sentiments
favorables à son égard c'est la fameuse
idée du Doux commerce selon laquelle les
interactions économiques pacifient les
rapports humains les choses semblent
toutefois plus compliquées dans les
faits
quid de la violence dans les anciennes
civilisations
petite interruption parce que je me dis
que si tu m'écoutes c'est pas pour
devenir philosophe professionnel non tu
m'écoutes parce que tu veux te préparer
de la manière la plus efficace qui soit
pour réussir tes dissertations de
culture générale et du coup je me dis
que tu as probablement compris qu'un
cours de 300 pages n'est pas la solution
au contraire c'est plutôt le problème si
tu as conscience de ce problème alors
j'ai une solution pour toi chaque année
je prépare 50 paragraphes modèle sur le
thème que j'ai baptisé avec un brin de
provocation 50 paragraphes tout cuits
l'idée est simple tu n'as plus besoin de
rédiger toi-même le développement de tes
dissertations puisque tu connais déjà
une cinquantaine de paragraphes très
rédigé qui permettent de défendre tous
les arguments envisageables surtout les
sujets envisageables avec les références
idéales et si je sais que ça marche pour
tous les sujets c'est parce que je
traite moi-même tous les sujets
possibles dans un premier temps c'est
comme ça que je trouve les arguments des
paragraphes d'ailleurs depuis plusieurs
années je fournis avec les paragraphes
une cinquantaine de plans travailler
modèle les avantages de cette solution
c'est que tu n'as plus besoin de cours
que tu n'as plus besoin de chercher un
plan ni des arguments et que tu seras
surnauté parce que les paragraphes sont
bien mieux rédigés que si tu les rédigé
toi-même ce qui fait que ta copine sort
du lot les élèves me disent aussi qu'ils
sont beaucoup moins stressés pendant les
preuves qu'ils se sentent confiant et à
l'aise bref mais 50 paragraphes tout
cuits te feront gagner facilement et
rapidement des points tout en gagnant
beaucoup de temps ce qui te permet de
gagner des points dans les autres
matières tout particulièrement en maths
si tu veux en savoir plus clique sur le
lien qui apparaît en haut à droite de la
vidéo ou bien clique sur celui qui est
dans la description ou bien encore tape
directement mais l'idée
cg.com/50ptc dans la barre de recherche
et puis si tu as des questions écris-moi
à romain@mi l'idée cg.com
quid de la violence dans les anciennes
civilisations les anciennes
civilisations qui servent de repères
pour la culture occidentale sont les
civilisations bibliques la Grèce antique
et la Rome antique
l'Iliade et l'Odyssée d'Homère offre un
aperçu de la violence de la Grèce
antique le récit se déroule à la période
mythique de la guerre de Troie aux
environs du XIIIe siècle avant
Jésus-Christ mais comme il a été rédigé
bien plus tard il reflète en réalité la
vie en particulier la propension à la
violence des tribus et chefs fris en
Méditerranée orientale dans la première
moitié du premier millénaire avant
Jésus-Christ
les hommes de cette époque voient la
guerre comme un aspect inexorable de
l'existence leur fatalisme se trahit par
le fait qu'il rapporte la guerre à la
colère des dieux plutôt que de
l'envisager comme un problème humain
soluble nous sommes des hommes à qui
Dieu ce je le vois inflige le dessin de
dévider le fil des guerres douloureuses
de nos plus jeunes années jusqu'à notre
vieillesse jusqu'à l'heure où chacun de
nous doit succomber dit Ulysse dans
l'Odyssée d'Homère
les descriptions d'Homère sont
cohérentes avec les connaissances
archéologiques ethnographiques et
historiques dont nous disposons elle
montre que les guerres de la Grèce
antique sont tout aussi totale que les
guerres des nations modernes voici
comment se produit une attaque les
soldats approchent du rivage dans des
embarcations rapides ce qui leur permet
de mettre à ça que les habitations
côtières avant l'intervention des
voisins en général il tue les hommes ils
payent le bétail et les autres biens
meubles ils enlèvent les femmes les
asservices et les viols les héros de
l'ilia de considèrent les femmes comme
un butin légitime les combats infligent
au corps humain une violence digne de
nos films d'horreur et puis laissent des
monceaux de cadavres en délitement sur
le champ de bataille ce scénario
explique la psychologie des Grecs du
temps d'Homère les hommes vivent dans
l’hypothèse d'une mort soudaine et
violente les femmes ont peur pour leur
mari et enfants elles guettent avec
inquiétude dévoile à l'horizon qui
peuvent être annonciatrices d'une
nouvelle vie de viol et d'esclavage
l'Ancien Testament qui est la première
partie de la Bible chrétienne ne
composait d'un ensemble de textes
religieux et historiques du peuple juif
l'Ancien Testament offre un aperçu des
vies et des valeurs des civilisations
proche-orientales au milieu du premier
millénaire avant Jésus-Christ or la
violence est un thème majeur de l'Ancien
Testament parmi les épisodes de violence
les plus célèbres on peut citer le
meurtre d'Abel par son frère aîné Kane
ce qui fait de quand le premier
meurtrier de l'humanité avait15 sont les
fils d'Adam et Eve le massacre des
habitants de Sodome et gomores qui sont
des villes voisines Dieu décide de les
engloutir dans un déluge de soufre et de
feu pour punir leurs péchés que les
théologiens réduiront à la sexualité non
reproductive enfin troisième épisode de
violence parmi les plus célèbres de
l'Ancien Testament le sacrifice d'Isaac
les valeurs morales d'Abraham le père du
peuple hébreu sont mises à l'épreuve
lorsque Dieu lui ordonne d'emmener son
fils Isaac au sommet d'une montagne de
lui lier les mains et de l'égorger et de
brûler son corps en guise de sacrifice
Isaac n'était parié que parce qu'au
dernier moment un ange vient arrêter la
main du Père
les récits de l'Ancien Testament
incluent les violences les plus graves
l'esclavage le viol la torture la
mutilation le sacrifice et même le
génocide de tribu voisine il banalise la
peine de mort prescrite pour l'adultère
l'homosexualité le manque de respect
envers les parents ou encore le
blasphème comme l'illustre l'épisode de
Sodome et gomorph la justice divine est
d'une sévérité extrême et le tourisme le
génocide de peuples entiers par exemple
les hits les amorithes les Cananéens etc
la vengeance humaine est légitimée par
la loi du talion qui apparaît à
plusieurs reprises avec la même image de
l’œil et de la dent enfin les pauvres
animaux prennent cher ils sont
régulièrement sacrifiés pour honorer
Dieu pour célébrer des fêtes religieuses
pour expier les péchés ou encore pour
sceller des alliances
mais si malheur arrive tu paieras vie
pour vie
œil pour œil dent pour Don main pour
main pied pour pieds brûlure pour
brûlures blessure pour blessures
meurtrissures pour meurtrissures est-il
écrit dans l'Ancien Testament exode 21
en conclusion l’ancien testament dépeint
un monde d'une sauvagerie stupéfiante
les gens réduisent en esclavage violent
assassine des membres de leur famille
proche les chefs de guerre massacrent
des civils de façon indiscriminée y
compris des enfants les femmes sont
achetées vendues enlevées comme objet
sexuel quant à Dieu il torture et
massacre hommes et femmes par centaines
de milliers pour simple désobéissance ou
même sans aucune raison les violences
ces atroces ne sont pas rares et elles
impliquent toutes les figures
principales du récit
le judaïsme et le christianisme
cependant donné plus important à des
textes sacrés bien moins violents que
l’ancien testament le Talmud qui compile
le savoir religieux des rabbins pour le
judaïsme et le Nouveau Testament qui
relate notamment le parcours de
Jésus-Christ pour le christianisme plus
particulièrement on oppose souvent la
conception chrétienne de l'amour à la
violence des peintres et valorisée dans
l'Ancien Testament l'innovation en terme
de valeur est double premier versant
Jésus-Christ prescrit d'aimer son
prochain comme soi-même et second
versant il prescrit d'aimer tous les
hommes quels qu'ils soient
indépendamment de leur mérite comme de
leur identité cela inclut donc les
ennemis le chrétien a donc un devoir de
bienveillance universel et
inconditionnel qui constitue un idéal de
non-violence envisagé dans une
perspective historique le Nouveau
Testament indique une évolution des
mentalités chez les peuples des deux
premiers siècles
la Rome antique est une civilisation
ambivalente à l'égard de la violence
d'un côté elle est un exemple de la
capacité d'un empire une organisation
politique autoritaire qui s'étend sur
des peuples distincts à pacifié les
rapports humains c'est ce qu'on appelle
la PACS Romana père romaine en français
l'Empire romain a connu une période de
stabilité politique et de prospérité qui
s'étend grosso modo sur les deux
premiers siècles qui sont également la
période de l'histoire et de l'écriture
du Nouveau Testament l'arôme de cette
époque connaît peu de conflits internes
pas de guerre majeure elle consolide le
pouvoir impérial développe les
infrastructures à travers les provinces
et enfin le commerce et la culture cette
paix impériale romaine illustre les deux
théories de référence concernant l'effet
de l'organisation politique sur la
violence tout d'abord la théorie du
Léviathan de Hobbs selon laquelle la
puissance de l'autorité publique est
garantit la sécurité nécessaire à la
civilisation et puis ensuite la
définition de l'État comme détenteur du
monopole de la violence légitime par le
sociologue Alaman Max Weber dans le
savant et le politique selon cette
théorie le pouvoir politique étatique
entraîne le déclin de la violence dans
la communauté car il organise en
interdisant l'usage de la violence à
tout membre groupe ou entités de la
communauté qui n'agit pas en tant
qu'agent du pouvoir politique
comme d'autres empires dans l'histoire
de l'humanité Rome s'est développé avec
des méthodes brutales mais ces profits
ont fait progresser la philosophie les
arts la justice et même la morale les
Romains justifiaient leur domination en
affirmant qu'ils apportaient au barbare
des justices et raffinement
l'historien romain tacite rapporte le
discours du chef breton calgacus avant
une bataille contre l'armée romaine
discours qui dénonce la brutalité des
conquêtes romaines et leur justification
de la violence sous couvert de
civilisations et de paix il pille tue et
ravisses par faux prétexte de
gouvernement et là où ils font un désert
il l'appelle paix rapporte tacite dans
sa vie d'Agricola
seulement dans notre côté la violence
est très répandue dans la Rome antique
elle se manifeste notamment dans les
guerres d'expansion et de conquêtes dans
les combats de gladiateurs dans les
arènes dans les exécutions publiques de
criminels et d'esclaves les persécutions
de certains groupes religieux comme les
chrétiens la concurrence féroce pour le
pouvoir ou encore dans les conflits
politiques internes qui conduisaient
souvent à des assassinats le plus
célèbre étant celui de César de surcroît
la mentalité populaire ne condamnait pas
la violence dans le Colisée qui
symbolise aujourd'hui l'Empire défoule
comparable à celles des stats actuels
jouissaient du spectacle de cruauté de
masse nous connaissons les combats de
gladiateurs mais les spectateurs
pouvaient aussi assister au viol d'une
femme nue attachée à un poteau ou encore
la voir se faire déchiqueter par des
animaux autre exemple emblématique la
crucifixion qui est le moyen de mise à
mort le plus célèbre à Rome c'était
d'ailleurs un châtiment courant dans
l'Antiquité la crucifixion est d’une
cruauté impensable le prisonnier était
notamment flageller par une sorte de
martinet dont les lanières étaient
serties de Pierre aiguisées qui pénétrer
profondément dans le corps et former
ainsi des lambots de chair
sanguinolantes on peut se faire une idée
de cette torture en regardant le film La
Passion du Christ
[Musique]
quelle forme la violence collective
prend-elle
la forme de violence collective la plus
emblématique et la guerre un conflit
armé entre des groupes humains organisés
on parle aussi de violence organisées
Voltaire a violemment dénoncé la guerre
par la bouche d'un personnage de Candide
ce qui n'a pas empêché de faire grossir
sa fortune en fournissant les armées un
million d'assassins en régiment monté
courant d'un bout de l'Europe à l'autre
exerce le meurtre et le brigandage avec
discipline pour gagner son pain parce
qu'il n'a pas de métier plus honnête
voici un bref aperçu de la violence
organisée en Europe depuis la
Renaissance
2400 à 1600 les conflits restent à un
niveau bas mais constant les guerres de
religion entre le 16e et le 17e siècle
représente un pic de violence organisé
ça se calme ensuite jusqu'à la fin du
XVIIIe siècle la Révolution française et
l'épopée napoléonienne relance la
violence c'est moins violent au milieu
et à la fin du 19e siècle la violence
organisée explose dans la première
moitié du XXe siècle une longue paix
entre guillemets s'installe dans la
seconde moitié du 20e siècle
il ressort de cet aperçu que l'Europe
moderne s'est développée dans un
contexte de guerre fréquente mais peu
étendue d'un côté les conflits sont
devenus moins nombreux à mesure que les
entités politiques se consolident en
état plus grand mais de l'autre côté les
conflits se firent de plus en plus
meurtrier à cause d'une révolution
militaire les guerres modernes
mobilisent plus de participants et
impliquent plus de civils les armées
sont plus grandes et plus efficaces
[Musique]
par le général de Gaulle en France et
celle de l'avion ses révolutions datent
de la fin de la première guerre mondiale
et enfin dernière caractéristique de la
guerre moderne qui apparaît au XIXe
siècle une course à l'innovation dans
l'armement
ainsi la guerre et la forme de violence
collective la plus emblématique parce
qu'elle est une constante de l'histoire
de l'Europe du deuxième millénaire pour
les classes dirigeantes elle fait partie
de l'ordre des choses les élites
considèrent donc la paix comme un bref
intervalle entre deux guerres
pour autant la guerre n'est pas l'unique
forme de violence collective on
distingue encore des violences diffusent
comme des rixes des bagarres entre
groupes entre communautés villageoises
ou religieuse des émeutes populaires
contre la vie chère le brigandage le
banditisme de telle violence surgissait
souvent en Europe jusqu'au XVIIIe siècle
lors d'explosion de misère ou de
révoltes contre l'impôt et les émeutes
de banlieue sont un exemple moderne
autre forme de violence collective les
soulèvements et révolutions les
révolutions anglaises de 1642 et 1688 la
Révolution française de 1789 les
journées révolutionnaires européennes
tout au long du XIXe siècle la
Révolution russe de 1917 sont les
exemples les plus connus il s'agit d'une
violence collective moderne entre
guillemets les violences diffusent étant
des formes anciennes entre guillemets
les soulèvements et révolutions
présupposent l'identification d'un
pouvoir central à conquérir et un projet
général de réorganisation de la société
autre forme de violence collective la
violence de l'autorité politique pour
établir pour maintenir ou pour faire
fonctionner le pouvoir politique par
exemple les despote étirants la
répression politique exercée par les
forces de maintien de l'ordre dans les
États modernes ou encore la terreur
révolutionnaire autre forme de violence
collective le terrorisme qui se
développe spectaculairement depuis des
années 1960 le terrorisme définit comme
un acte de violence prémédité commis par
un acteur non étatique contre des civils
avec un objectif politique religieux ou
social visant à forcer la main à un
gouvernement à intimider la population
ou à transmettre un message à un public
plus large et enfin dernière forme de
violence collective la guerre civile un
conflit armé qui oppose des groupes au
sein d'un même pays et qui engendre
souvent l’ultra-violence des tortures
des exécutions sommaires des mutilations
des viols et des meurtres de masse
comment expliquer la violence collective
étant donné que la guerre est un fond
omniprésent de l'histoire des
civilisations les penseurs occidentaux
ont tenté de les lucider
voici trois théories de référence
tout d'abord tu City l'historien
athénien du cinquième siècle avant
Jésus-Christ qui a donné naissance à
l'histoire telle que nous la concevons
aujourd'hui suicides étudie les causes
de la guerre dans la guerre du
Péloponnèse où il raconte le conflit qui
a opposé Athènes à Sparte entre 431
avant Jésus-Christ et 4004 avant
Jésus-Christ de son point de vue les
conflits entre état s'explique
principalement par la peur par la
concurrence pour les ressources ou par
la volonté de puissance des dirigeants
il estime par exemple que la peur plus
précisément la tendance d'une puissance
établie à agresser préventivement une
puissance émergente il estime que c'est
la cause fondamentale de la guerre du
Péloponnèse la cause la plus vraie est
aussi la moins avouée de la guerre c'est
à mon sens que les Athéniens en
s'accroissant donnèrent de
l'appréhension au lacets démoniens les
contraignant ainsi à la guerre écris-tu
si dites dans la guerre du Péloponnèse
c'est ce que les géopolithologues et
spécialistes des relations
internationales appellent le piège de
tussidique ce concept leur fait par
exemple le craindre que les États-Unis
attaquent la Chine afin de préserver le
régime
deuxième théorie de référence quand le
plus grand philosophe allemand des
lumières veut résoudre le problème de la
guerre dans de la paix perpétuelle il
part du principe que les États
continueront de s'agresser en l'absence
d'ordre politique international il plaît
de donc pour l'établissement d'un
système de coopération qui est le
pouvoir de tenir les nations en respect
solution qui revient à établir un
Léviathan international entre guillemets
ils mettent en évidence une autre cause
de la guerre les gouvernements non
démocratiques en effet les démocraties
tendent à éviter la guerre dans la
mesure où les bénéfices de la guerre
vont à ceux qui règnent sur un pays
tandis que le coût de la guerre est payé
par les citoyens troisième théorie de
référence close vite un théoricien
militaire prussien du 19e siècle clause
vite se confronte la théorie à la
réalité du terrain
il est l'auteur de la fameuse formule
selon laquelle la guerre et la
continuation de la politique par
d'autres moyens l'italien Machiavel
avait déjà affirmé à la Renaissance dans
le prince qu'un dirigeant politique peut
recourir à la guerre pour préserver ou
pourrait tendre son pouvoir la guerre
n'est pas seulement un acte politique
mais un véritable instrument politique
une continuation des relations
politiques un accomplissement de
celle-ci par d'autres moyens écrit
klausvitz dans de la guerre
en pratique la guerre s’arrête lorsque
le vaincu est satisfait par ce qu'il a
obtenu et qu'il est en mesure d'empêcher
le vaincu de se réarmer dans le détail
le calcul politique est préconise
l'arrêt du conflit lorsque la
supériorité de l'un des belligérant ne
peut plus être renversé ou lorsque la
situation ne peut plus être évaluée la
stratégie et les aléas font comparer la
guerre à un jeu mais elle est un moyen
sérieux au service d'une fin sérieuse
clausvitz estime que les enjeux
politiques et les réalités du champ de
bataille empêchent la montée aux
extrêmes que l'es craindre les passions
humaines la guerre moderne est une
ritualisation de la violence les
adversaires s'entendent pour ne pas
dépasser certaines limites et ne pas
sortir de certaines formes
les penseurs ont également théorisé les
autres formes de violence collective
aristote dit dans les politiques que les
inégalités et le mépris des dirigeants
sont susceptibles de provoquer la
violence des groupes sociaux défavorisés
le marxisme requalifiera les violences
diffusent comme des conflits de classe
le freudisme les requalifiera lui comme
une libération d'inhibition
Pareto un sociologue italien des 19e et
20e siècle Pareto conçoit une révolution
comme le remplacement d'une élite qui a
perdu sa compétence et sa volonté de
puissance par une nouvelle élite par
exemple la bourgeoisie a remplacé la
noblesse lors de la Révolution française
cette théorie développée dans le Traité
de sociologie générale de Pareto
s'appelle la circulation des élites
l'histoire des sociétés et celle de la
succession de minorités privilégiée qui
se forment qui lutte et qui arrive au
pouvoir en profite et tombe en décadence
pour être remplacé par d'autres
minorités l'histoire est un cimetière
d'aristocratie écrit par eto dans son
Traité de sociologie générale
Machiavel justifie la violence de
l'autorité politique dans le prince
comme un moyen nécessaire pour atteindre
certains objectifs probablement marqués
par l'instabilité et l'insécurité de
l'Italie de son époque il voit les
hommes ordinaires comme des tyrans en
puissance susceptibles de détruire
l'ordre social si les dirigeants ne
savent pas usés de la force au bon
moment la Boétie un humaniste français
du 16ème siècle abordera la question du
point de vue de la multitude opprimée
dans son fameux discours de la servitude
volontaire si une multitude peut être
soumise à un tyran qui est seul et pas
moins faible que chacun c'est parce que
la multitude est fascinée et paralysée
dans la crainte
Serge netchalieff un révolutionnaire
russe du 19e siècle prône la violence et
la destruction sans réserve pour
atteindre les objectifs révolutionnaires
dans son catéchisme du révolutionnaire
il appelle les révolutionnaires à
utiliser tous les moyens nécessaires y
compris la terreur pour renverser
l'ordre établi Lénine le premier
dirigeant de l'URSS défendra la même
thèse d'une cinquantaine d'années plus
tard dans son essai leur morale et la
nôtre le titre signifie que la
révolution communiste ne doit pas être
jugée à l'aune de la morale bourgeoise
qui est faussement universelle mais à
l'eau ne de la morale révolutionnaire
qui confère une valeur morale à tous
ceux qui fait avancer la cause
révolutionnaire
dans la République Platon conçoit la
guerre civile comme une maladie interne
qui détruit le corps politique de
l’intérieur elle porte la rivalité entre
les hommes à son comble le risque est
grand en démocratie car elle répand le
laxisme à tous les niveaux de la société
il contamine même le monde animal estime
Platon dans les politiques Aristote qui
réfléchit de manière plus concrète
mettant lumière la même cause
fondamentale la rivalité entre les
hommes mais il estime que le risque est
plus grand dans une oligarchie parce que
ce sont souvent les luttes entre grandes
familles qui engendre les guerres
civiles
devient-elle de plus en plus violente
le psychologue canadien Steven Pinker
qui est prof à Harvard a réalisé un
sondage auprès de citoyens anglais les
gens interrogés estiment que le 20e
siècle a été un peu plus violent que le
14e siècle en terme de domicile en
réalité malgré les guerres mondiales les
génocides et les totalitarismes etc le
taux d'homicide a été divisé par 100
entre le 14e siècle et le 20e siècle ce
sondage montre que les générations
modernes oublient la propension à la
violence de leurs ancêtres
dans les faits le déclin de la violence
est incontestable la tendance globale
est sans équivoque visible à des
échelles qui se comptent en millénaire
ou en année qu'on considère les
campagnes guerrières ou les fessées
donnés aux enfants voici quelques
éléments de preuves le passage du mode
de vie du chasseur cueilleur à
l'agriculture a divisé la probabilité
d'une mort violente par environ 5 estime
les anthropologues en Europe le taux
domicile est passé de 100 par an pour
100000 habitants ou 14e siècle à 10 au
17e siècle et à un de nos jours en
France il y a deux fois moins de
meurtres dans les années 2010 que dans
les années 1990 autre élément de preuve
les guerres du passé ont causé des
effets bien plus ravageurs rapportés à
la population totale qu'il ne le paraît
si on prend en compte leurs effets
indirects tels que les famines et les
maladies
du Moyen-Âge à l'époque classique les
populations faisaient les frais des
rivalités entre pouvoir locaux les
chevaliers comptent duc et prince ne
cessaient de s'attaquer et de se venger
des agressions passées on s'efforçant de
ruiner leurs adversaires en tuant et en
mutilant les paysans en brûlant les
villages et en détruisant les récoltes
autre élément de preuve jusqu'au 18e
siècle la torture était pratiquée
ouvertement la pendaison le supplice de
la roue l'empalement les cartes
tellement par des chevaux et le supplice
du bûcher était monnaie courante
preuve l'histoire européenne ne comprend
également des phénomènes de violence de
grande ampleur comme l'esclavage
l'Inquisition ou la chasse aux sorcières
enfin la violence domestique qui est une
des formes de violence les plus
répandues dans le monde ABC de manière
spectaculaire au cours du deuxième
millénaire
en définitive l’europe occidentale du
tournant du 21e siècle et le lieu le
plus sûr de l'histoire de l'humanité son
taux d'homicide avoisinant une victime
pour 100000 habitants et le plancher
qu'il est possible d'atteindre car même
la plus paisible des sociétés ne peut
pas éradiquer la violence de plus une
violence modérée sera toujours
nécessaire sous la forme de force de
police et d'armée afin de dissuader la
prédation ou de mettre hors d'état de
nuire ce qui ne se laisse pas dissuader
le déclin de la violence et la chose la
plus importante qui se soit jamais
produite dans l'histoire de l'humanité
affirme Stephen Pinker dans la part
d'ange en nous
comment expliquer le déclin de la
violence humaine le sociologue allemand
Norbert Elias donne une réponse
convaincante dans son chef-d’œuvre sur
le processus de civilisation il attribue
la diminution de la violence en Europe à
une vaste évolution psychologique
consécutive à la diffusion de nouvelles
normes sociales depuis la fin du
Moyen-âge les individus ont appris à
inhiber leur pulsion à anticiper les
conséquences à long terme et à
considérer les pensées et sentiments
d'autrui la culture de l'honneur
légitimement la vengeance a été
remplacée par une culture de la dignité
qui valorise la maîtrise de soi ce
nouvel idéal s'est propagé des
aristocrates et chevaliers aux autres
classes jusqu'à intégrer finalement la
culture dans son ensemble
cependant le processus de civilisation
repose lui-même sur d'autres facteurs la
centralisation des monarchies et la
prospérité notamment et d'autres
évolutions ultérieures ont contribué à
pacifier les sociétés occidentales
voici les facteurs les plus probables du
déclin de la violence
l'émergence déta stable à réduit les
violences entre individus et groupes qui
doivent désormais résoudre leurs conflit
par l'intermédiaire d'institution et de
processus légaux cette évolution
correspond à la théorie du Léviathan de
Hobbs et à celle du monopole de la
violence légitime devait Weber des états
stables sont également plus à même
d’éviter la guerre grâce à la diplomatie
autre facteur probable du déclin de la
violence le développement du commerce
qui est d'ailleurs favorisé par
l'émergence d'État stable le
développement du commerce a stimuler la
coopération et rendu la violence
coûteuse à partir de la fin du Moyen-âge
les royaumes en pleine expansion ont
consolidé une infrastructure d'échanges
notamment à travers la monnaie et
l'application des contrats cette
infrastructure la construction de route
et d’horloge la levée des tabous
frappant l’intérêt l'innovation et la
concurrence tout cela a rendu le
commerce plus attrayant peu à peu les
marchands artisans et bureaucrates ont
remplacé les preux chevaliers
autre facteur probable du déclin de la
violence l'expansion de l'empathie
signifie que l'homme veut le bien de
plus en plus de ses semblables et même
d'autres êtres le philosophe australien
Peter Singer connu comme l'auteur de la
Bible de la défense des droits des
animaux Peter Singer avance dans The
expending circle que les êtres humains
ont été pourvus par la sélection
naturelle d'un noyau d'empathie envers
leurs proches et leurs alliés et qu'ils
ont graduellement étendu cette empathie
à des cercles toujours plus larges
d'être vivant de la famille et du
village au clan à la tribu à la nation à
l'espèce puis enfin à l'ensemble des
êtres doués de sensibilité
enfin dernier facteur probable du déclin
de la violence le progrès de la
rationalité des crédibilisent les
justifications de la violence en
particulier la scolarisation du 20e
siècle a démocratisé l'intelligence
abstraite qui favorise la maîtrise de
soi et l'empathie en donnant un individu
la faculté de s'extraire de son
expérience immédiate le raisonnement
scientifique imprègne désormais les
raisonnements de la vie quotidienne
le déclin de la violence aboutit à
l'idéal de la non-violence qui prévaut
en Occident ou les individus deviennent
sensibles à toute forme d'agression
cette évolution est illustrée par la
diffusion du concept de micro-agression
inventé par un psychiatre de Harvard à
la fin des trentes glorieuses qui
désigne une discrimination subtile une
remarque par exemple envers un membre
d'une communauté marginalisée ainsi les
mentalités élargissent la notion de
violence jusqu'à en faire un synonyme de
domination s'impose alors l'idée que
tout est violence
quoi que fiable le constat du déclin de
la violence mérite deux nuances
principales première nuance principale
il n'est pas toujours facile de comparer
les sociétés modernes avec celle du
passé qui ne disposait pas des mêmes
capacités d'archivage et puis second
nuance principale il y a des essors de
violence sur de courtes périodes comme
lors de la Révolution culturelle
occidentale qui s'étend grosso modo de
1960 à 1990 d'ailleurs en valorisant
l'expression libre et naturelle la
révolution culturelle est allée à
rebours de l'évolution psychologique du
processus de civilisation mise en
évidence par Norbert Elias évolution
psychologique et qui repose sur la
maîtrise de soi
si tu aimes l'esprit de cette vidéo à
savoir travailler avec des idées claires
pour être le plus efficace possible
alors tu devrais t'inscrire à mes 50
paragraphes tout cuits sur le thème de
la violence ce sont 50 paragraphes prêts
à l'emploi qui couvrent tous les
arguments possibles sur le thème de la
violence avec dans chaque paragraphe la
référence idéale la plupart du temps
classique mais aussi parfois original
pour justifier l'argument ils sont
accompagnés d'une cinquantaine de
plantes détaillées modèles qui
permettent de traiter tous les sujets
possibles du coup tu réussiras
facilement tes dissertations sans
apprendre ton cours sans chercher un
plan ni des arguments et sans rédiger le
développement tu seras scandaleusement
surnauté grâce au style simple fluide
efficace et facile à imiter avec lequel
je rédige les paragraphes enfin mes 50
paragraphes tout cuits c'est aussi la
solution la plus rapide pour préparer un
DS grâce à la playlist audio tes
révisions se résumeront à écouter les
paragraphes pendant une heure dans
toutes les circonstances imaginables en
marchant en courant dans les transports
à la salle de sport ou encore au fond de
la classe par exemple Léa m'a raconté
qu'elle écoutait les paragraphes en
faisant du vélo d'appartement et étant
donné qu'elle en faisait chaque jour
elle savait tout ce qu'elle avait besoin
de savoir pour ces dissertations de
culture générale sans avoir passé une
seule minute dans son cours comme ça
fait 7 ans que je propose mes
paragraphes tout cuits j'ai reçu
beaucoup d'autres témoignages regarde
celui-ci qui date de 2017 l'année
dernière je plafonnais à 8 en
dissertation j'étais dans les tout
derniers aujourd'hui le prof rend les
copies je majeur la classe avec 17
effectivement l'avantage de mes
paragraphes tout cuits c'est que tu
gagnes des points rapidement pas dans
six mois mais dès le prochain ds le
prochain témoignage est celui d'Alex il
m'a écrit sur messenger je me suis
rappelé que je ne t'avais jamais
remercié pour ta méthode qui m'a on peut
le dire sauver Alex dit que mes
paragraphes tout cuits l'ont sauvé parce
que la culture générale n'était pas sa
matière forte et qu'en plus il ne l'a
quasiment pas travaillé avec son niveau
il pensait se ramasser au concours mais
il a fini avec 13 à HEC et 15 à l'échec
la prestigieuse école qu'il a intégré le
dernier témoignage que je veux te
montrer est un peu drôle Roland m'écrit
même si j'ai eu 15 sur 20 je pense que
c'est plutôt paragraphe tout cuit très
bien rédigé que grâce à ma dissertation
Roland pense qu'il a été surnommé parce
que le style de mes paragraphes tout de
suite a fait sortir sa copie du Lot je
sais j'ai promis que c'était le dernier
témoignage mais je veux quand même t'en
montrer un tout dernier parce que c'est
celui d'un prof j'ai flouté beaucoup de
choses dans son email parce qu'il est
prof de culture générale dans une prépa
prestigieuse en plus d'être correcteur à
HEC il m'écrit notamment votre méthode
est excellente et correspond tout à fait
à ce que je crois est très efficace pour
la préparation des concours j'ai même
rencontré ce prof il m'a avoué qu'il
faisait désormais la même chose que moi
il prépare des paragraphes modèles pour
sa classe voilà voilà je t'ai déjà
montré un témoignage de plus que ce que
j'avais promis il y en a encore beaucoup
d'autres sur la page de présentation si
tu veux en savoir plus sur mes
paragraphes tout cuit clique sur le lien
qui apparaît en haut à droite de la
vidéo ou bien clique sur celui qui est
dans la description ou bien encore tape
directement 1000 idées
cg.com/50pc dans la barre de recherche
et puis si tu as des questions écris-moi
à romain@mie l'idée cg.com bon courage
pour le travail
[Musique]